hi there I'm James Williams from glamour
and I'm very excited today to be invited
round to the kitchen our lifestyle
blogger and YouTube sensation Naomi
smart hello Naomi hi hi first of all
thanks for having us round very exciting
time for you because your debut cookbook
Eat Smart is out right now yes how
excited are you so excited it's just
being like the most amazing experience
and I can't believe it's finally here
tell us a bit about how it came to be
and also for those people who are not
one of your 1.7 million YouTube
subscribers and these without followers
explain a little bit about you know your
history in your story and also how this
book came to be in what your general
philosophy years with approach to
healthy eating and lifestyle about four
years ago I decided to just start eating
a lot healthily and it was all about not
restricting my diet and going on some
kind of fad diet or anything it was just
about introducing more fresh foods like
fruit and vegetables more whole grains
and then eventually that led to a fully
plant-based diet and it was never like a
negative thing like I can't have this
anymore I've got to you know stick to
this diet it was such an exciting
positive transition and that Sun I just
started creating all my own recipes and
I started writing them all down and
that's when the book came around this is
it and we're actually gonna make one of
the recipes from the book and I have to
say it looks amazing
yes machete and meatballs yeah I'm very
excited to try this so shall we just
crack on and get on with it
[Music]
so it starts off by making it Dean
equals they're not like normal meetings
as you know them they're obviously vegan
meatballs that are made from lentils
walnuts
beans so yeah we're going to stop that
first of all we just need to start
frying the onion so I'm going to start
dicing that what was it then that made
you really have it so like bummer but
when you really thought actually I
really do care about what I'm putting
into my body and I want to think about a
bit more and actually start
experimenting having fun with food yeah
I think I started just thinking about
being a bit healthy I was going to the
gym I'm not really into it absolutely
loved it and then I slowly started
incorporating more like healthy foods
into my diet it was when I did a lot of
research online about the plant-based
cyclists it just kept coming up I kept
reading about it and I thought you know
what I can't really knock anything until
I try it right now so we're just going
to fry off the onion just going to chop
up those apricots as well so I just
roughly chop them up and I'm also going
to add a garlic clove into there with
the onion this is by the way like my
favorite Badgers are just garlic crusher
really so much easier
as opposed to food processor blitz them
and then literally just add the
remaining ingredients so I've got those
cooked lentils there and then the onion
and garlic that we fried this is just
half of that onion and then I'm also
adding half a tin of black beans two
tablespoons of buckwheat flour and I'm
also going to add a teaspoon of dried
basil and teaspoon of dried oregano
I just love pubs spices and everything
that's one thing my book I just love it
and then we're just going to blend that
all together and then that's when I'm
just going to stay
the remaining diced onion that we have
and also the apricots it's nice to have
that hint of sweetness from the April
just adds a whole other kind of
dimension as the meatballs sometimes
this is just best to get your house I
was gonna say I be can I get my hand in
there setting some greaseproof paper on
a baking tray and then you literally
just mold this into people's
okay so first our meatballs I'm just
going to put them in the oven that will
be enough about 30 minutes butternut
squash can be a bit of a bugger to cut I
find you so such like a solid vegetable
isn't it yeah and so yeah this is for
these porchetta now so I'm just going to
peel those those and then you just cut
them in half and literally refuse this
spiralizer they're going to go in the
oven for the last 10 minutes but the
meatballs are in
so I'm just going to add the core Shetty
straight into a baking tray and I'm just
going to drizzle over some olive oil and
then they go in the oven for 10 minutes
so well that is all in the oven I'm just
going to heat up some tomato sauce I
made this earlier but it's so simple
literally vine-ripe tomatoes with some
onion garlic basil slow systems when you
just simmer it for about 15 minutes and
then I just blitz it in my nutribullet
so simple so I'm just going to heat up
get the squash out ladies been cooking
away for ten minutes
yeah been good yeah looks amazing there
we go
and then I've got the sauce here
bubbling away so I'm just going to pour
that over
and then the main stock shall we pop
meatballs finish that off with some
fresh basil and I also like to sprinkle
over to some nutritional yeast this is
like totally optional you don't have to
have this so there we have it there me
your delicious take on squash XT and
meatballs
thanks so much coming so it looks
absolutely delicious
so do try out this recipe and do a check
out other recipes from Naomi you can
grab the new issue of Glamour magazine
on shelves right now Naomi thank you so
much no thank you
that's going talking to this yeah
absolutely for more fun video somewhere
click down here